arguments are elegant and infinite sets
some people think a romantic but you
could legitimately ask what is all this
weird infinite stuff doing and of course
that's math for computer science and the
reason is that diagonal arguments turn
out to play a fundamental role in the
theory of computing and what we're going
to talk about now is the application of
diagonal arguments to show that there
are non computable sets and examine a
particular one so let's look at the
class of infinite binary strings now
we've seen that there are an uncountable
number of infinite binary strings and
that's because there was a simple
projection between the infinite binary
strings and the subsets of the natural
numbers that is the power set of n let's
look at the strings in the infinite
binary strings that we might think of
and called a computable string so what I
mean by a computable string is that
there's simply a procedure that will
tell me what its digits are so what I
mean is that the procedure applied to
argument n will return the nth digit of
the string asked that's the definition
of what I mean by saying S is computable
I can compute its digits whichever
digits are needed now we saw that there
were only a countable number of finite
binary sequences and I mentioned that
now because I want to think about
sequences over the slightly larger
alphabet instead of 0 1 the 256 ASCII
characters and by the same argument the
set of finite ASCII strings is also
countable you just list them in order of
length same argument that we use for the
binary strings now the point of looking
at the asking strings the 256 keyboard
characters is that every procedure that
we enter in through a computer we type
in an ASCII string every procedure can
be represented by an ASCII string and
since there are only countably many
finite ASCII strings it follows that
there are only countably many computable
procedures
now since in order to be a computable
infinite binary string there has to be a
procedure which computes its digits we
can immediately conclude that there are
only countably many infinite binary
sequences that are computable only
countably many computable infinite
binary sequences but I already said
there are an uncountable number of those
infinite binary sequences so it has to
be that there are non computable
sequences and uncomputable infinite
binary strings that exist so we can
conclude that as a matter of fact since
the set of infinite binary strings is
uncountable and the computable ones are
a countable subset there have to be an
uncountable number of non computable
infinite binary sequences most infinite
binary sequences are actually not
computable ok that's kind of abstract
thing to know they're out there and you
can't get a hold of them computationally
but the reasonable question to ask is
what do they look like and what we're
gonna see is that if you consider a
particular sensible concrete
computational problem of giving a
procedure figuring out whether it will
run and return a value successfully on
some argument or not is called testing
the whole thing property of procedures I
want to know given a procedure and an
argument that I could apply it to does
it return a value or does something else
bad happen it runs forever it returns an
error we don't get a satisfactory value
out and if it does what satisfactory
return something we say it holds and
what I'm kind of argue is that the
halting problem is not decidable that is
there's no procedure which given an
input that describes a procedure with a
fixed procedure can figure out what its
input is doing let's look at that in
more detail so let's think about string
procedures because we're thinking about
procedures being represented by ASCII
strings so let's think about procedures
that take a string argument so an
example of a procedure pay it might be
that when you apply pay to the string no
it returns to when
apply it to the string Albert it returns
wire when you apply it to this string of
weird symbols that causes an error and
you apply it to the sequence of
characters what now and it actually runs
forever these are just illustrations of
the kind of behavior that some weird
string procedure might exhibit so what I
want to think about is suppose that I
have a an a say string X a finite ASCII
string that's the one that defines this
procedure paid when I'm trying to run P
on the computer I have to type in s in
order to give the computer the
definition of P to tell it what to do
and I'm gonna say that s halts the
string has this property called whole
thing or halts if and only if this
procedure P that s describes return
successfully when it's applied to s this
is where we're kind of this is where
we're really doing a diagonal argument
we're taking the the s object the
procedure that's described by s and
applying it to s and that's kind of
going down the diagonal of s applied to
s or the nth row of the nth element of
the nth row in a pictorial diagonal
argument that's the idea that we're
going here but let's just go back to the
definition a string is said to halt if
when you interpret it as the description
of a procedure that takes a string
argument and you apply that string
procedure to that very same thing s you
successfully return that's the halting
problem and what I want to argue is that
it's impossible that there could be a
procedure Q that decided the property
halts of strengths that is to say Q
applied to a string returns yes if s
does return successfully FS waltz and it
returns no otherwise you applied to s
will say no if s runs forever or if s
has a type error or s does anything
other than successfully return a value
let's suppose for the sake of
contradiction that there was this halts
decider I claim there can't be such a
queue for the sake of contribution of
contradiction let's assume
was not then this is the trick that I'm
gonna do I'm gonna modify you to be to
act as though it was complementing the
diagonal more precisely this is what I'm
gonna do with you I'm gonna modify Q to
be another procedure Q Prime which just
behaves a little bit differently namely
Q prime of s returns yes when Q of s
returns null and Q prime of s returns
nothing no that is it doesn't hold if Q
of s returns yes so Q prime is like
complimenting the bits on the diagonal
but here's the precise definition Q of s
says no Q of prime of s says yes Q of s
says yes s halts successfully Q prime
then does not hold successfully it
returns nothing at all
let's go crank through the consequences
of these definitions so s halts means Q
prime of s returns nothing that was the
way we defined through prime of s now
let's let t be the text for Q prime we
said the Q prime was it if he was a
procedure then surely we can tweak this
procedure Q to get the procedure Q prime
so Q prime will have a text that
describes it it'll it'll be the ASCII
string that defines Q prime let's let
let t be that ASCII string what do we
have then by definition of halts T holds
if and only if the procedure that team
describes namely Q prime applied to T
returns a value successfully okay
now by definition of Q prime however Q
prime was the thing that on T it
returned a value successfully if and
only if it was not the case that T
equals okay so if you put those things
two things together that is we're
looking at team holds if and only if Q
prime of T returns and Q prime of T
returns the value successfully if and
only if not T halts then put the two
together and we have a contradiction tim
holtz if and only if T doesn't halt and
that contradiction says that our
original hypothesis that we had a Q that
would decide the halting problem can't
be right it's impossible to write a
procedure that determines of strings
whether they describe a procedure that
halts when applied to itself okay that
at least gives us some concrete problem
that we can say is it's not something
that a computer can do even though it's
a very well-defined and clear question
it's just not possible to get a computer
person computing a procedure that will
on an arbitrary string figure out the
problem the right answer any program
that applied two strings is trying to do
this job either it will give the wrong
answer or if it never gives the wrong
answer it means it doesn't give an
answer at all on some strings all right
well you could say that I don't really
care very much about whether a program
halts or not so let's look at how do you
apply the same reasoning or more
precisely how do you apply the Carolla
as a corollary of the fact that the
halting problem is not computable let's
talk about something that sounds closer
to a practical interest mainly type
checking so I want to think about the
type checking problem and what I want to
say is that that in fact there's no
string procedure that type checks of
procedures perfectly and so what I mean
is that I want to be able to write a
program that will look at a program task
and a task
test text an ASCII string that describes
a procedure and figure out whether that
ASCII string if you ran it would cause a
runtime type error that's what type
checkers are supposed to do they're
supposed to check your program figure
out whether the program will cause a
runtime type error if so it reports it
if not it says this program is safe
other things may go wrong but it's not
going to commit a runtime type error so
let's suppose that I had such a type
checking procedure C so what that means
is that for program text s C of s
returns yes if running s would cause a
runtime type error and C of s returns
null the output spring no otherwise if
would not cause a runtime type error in
other words s is safe all right now what
I claim is that if you give me see if I
have a procedure that's this perfect
type checker I can use C to build a
tester for halts which we said is
impossible so how would I use C to get a
halts tester H here's how I'm going to
tell you how to compute H of s how do
I'm gonna write a procedure here I'm
describing the procedure that that this
tester H carries out on argument s and
what it does is give an argument s it's
going to construct a new program that's
a small modification of s it's going to
construct this new program S prime that
acts like an interpreter for s so s is a
computing persona a computer program or
procedure I want to know whether if you
just run it it'll halt or not I'm gonna
tweak it a little bit so that s prime
acts like s but in a slightly modified
way and here's how s prime works s prime
is going to be an interpreter that
simulating step by step how s behaves
but at the moment that it discovers that
s is about to commit my runtime type
error that the next instruction that s
prime would execute in simulating s was
going to be a runtime type error s prime
will just skip it and who knows what the
consequences of skipping it will be but
it'll skip and just keep going okay and
if s prime in simulating program s
discovers that in fact s returns
successfully that is s halts then s
prime will purposely make a type error
so let's think about what that means
well actually let me just wrap up what
the definition of age is so the way H
works is give an input s it constructs
the program s prime and applies the type
checker C to s prime and returns the
same value that C does so what we can
figure out by these definitions is that
s holds the pro to the string
is a is a whole thing string if and only
if the string s prime makes a runtime
type error because remember the
interpreter which is what s prime was
behaving like was watching what s
simulating what s did and if s was going
to hold successfully s prime makes a
runtime type error that means that C is
gonna say s yes T s prime yes it has a
runtime type error and by definition of
H that means that H of s says yes
because H of s constructed s prime
infinite to see ok on the other hand if
s does not hold that means that that
something else goes wrong with s it's
not kind of successfully returned then s
prime when it's simulating s is never
gonna make a runtime type error because
that's the way s prime goes whenever it
detects that there would be about to be
a runtime type error it skips it so s
prime is likely to keep running forever
because it's simulating this program as
that doesn't halt
but it won't make a type error and that
means that C of s prime is gonna say no
no type error and H of s is going to say
no and that means that when s does not
hold H of s properly says no in other
words I've just walked through the
argument then this procedure H that I've
described actually is a decider for
halts and that's a contradiction H the
age that I gave you would solve the
halting problem if there was a perfect
type checker and there can't be a hoping
problem decider so there can't be a
perfect type checker C must make a
mistake it can't accurately predict
runtime errors and that is an example of
how you reason from this kind of
contrived halting problem that sort of
self referential whether the the string
procedure applied to its own definition
holds or not and we can apply it to all
sorts of questions and properties of
procedures that we really care about and
in fact the same reasoning really shows
that it's not just type checking as
kind of arbitrary example but there's
more or less no perfect checker for any
kind of property that precedes your
outcomes might exhibit which is why
computer scientists a theoretical
computer scientist interested in your
theory of computation have great respect
and interest in diagonal arguments
because they crystallise a whole set of
absolutely logical intrinsic limitations
on the power of computation